so you keep talking about leadership as
a real crisis of conformity can you
explain to us what do you mean by that
what do you see as a crisis of
conformity I think it's a crisis of
conformity when we continue to do
business and lead in the way we always
have yet the evidence is overwhelming
that the world needs us to change our
ways so let's look a little bit at that
evidence science has told us that we're
facing a climate crisis yet 40% of board
directors don't think climate belongs in
the boardroom and we have kids marching
in the streets now asking us to be
accountable for their future we have a
crisis of inequality we have
Yellowjackets not just in the streets of
friends but all over the world and yet
we continue to see examples of
businesses and other leaders fueling
that anger do you think the pitchforks
are coming I definitely think this is
not sustainable and the reason why it's
so difficult for us to deal with this
sort of these complicated crises that
are interrelated is that we are at the
lowest levels of trust we've ever been
that in the UK 3% of people trust their
government to solve the brexit crisis
and that was in December I think it's
probably gone down since then what do
you think new leadership actually looks
like we need courageous leaders yet they
have to be humble and they have to be
guided by a moral compass and the moral
compass is the combination of having a
social purpose you can't have your
license to operate anymore without a
purpose that contributes to society but
what to me has been missing from that
dialogue is a set of principles we
cannot just define why we exist we have
to define how we're going to do business
and how we're going to lead and to us
that has to be to solve these imminent
crisis the climate crisis the crisis of
inequality and the crisis of trust
so at the b-team we embrace
sustainability equality and
accountability as our principles do you
think this whole question
of purpose is really window dressing
they're saying what they think people
want to hear but they're actually not
making the fundamental changes that are
necessary a lot of people feel that way
and I think there's a growing momentum
behind that so I think the world is
calling for responsible leadership now
and any leader who wants to be around
for the 21st century really needs to
start thinking courageously and
holistically how they're gonna be part
of the solution and not window address
anymore you have to do it for real now
do you see anybody out there who's doing
it in a way that you think is actually
effective and has a real long-term
impact fortunately they have some great
leaders out there and just to give one
example Emanuel Ferber was one of the
newest members of the B team he's the
CEO of that known the world's largest
yogurt maker and major food company a
real global company he's so committed to
sustainability that he's not only
changed in the ways of his own business
but his entire supply chain he's so
committed to equality that when he took
her on a CEO and he said gender balance
matters he created a tender balanced
executive team and gave men and women
equal maternity and paternity leave he's
so committed to accountability that he
turned his us operations into a B
corporations now many of you may not
know what that is but that's a company
that holds itself responsible for not
just profit but its impact on people on
the planet and transparently report on
their performance and all of that
it's the largest B Corp in the world so
to me that's holistic courageous
leadership and it's it's really the
vision we all need to hold is this back
to the future I mean I wonder when I
think about companies by anheuser-busch
comes to mind in America a hundred-year
company that invested in its community
that gave a living wage before it ended
up you know losing and getting sold are
we really looking now for companies that
are global and community citizens or is
that something that is not even useful
anymore well you can do this as for the
reasons that there's it's risky actually
to continue without doing the right
thing now you can't attract the right
talent you can't attract customers and
increasingly you won't be able to
attract capital you might do it for risk
reasons you might do it for a business
opportunity reasons because this is
where the growth is
which is why many leaders are doing the
right thing but at the end of the day we
need to ask ourselves who are we holding
ourselves accountable for and if that
isn't the next generation I don't know
who so I want to just make very clear
because we tend to think about
leadership as only for those who sit in
positions of power to me leadership is
not at all like that there's a leader
inside of every single one of us and our
most important work in life is to
release that leader and I think one of
the greatest global examples we have of
someone who didn't no one gave her power
is the sixteen-year-old girl called
Gretta Thornburg she's from Sweden and a
few years ago she really became City has
Asperger and she became passionate about
our climate crisis learned everything
about it and faced with the evidence she
just felt so disappointed in her
leadership that she started striking in
front of the Swedish parliament and now
she has started a global movement and
hundreds and thousands of school kids
are out in the streets asking us to hold
ourselves accountable for their future
and I know one gave her that authority
and she now speaks to the leaders of the
world heads of states and really is
impacting the world so I really think
that when we think about leadership
today
it can't be defined to those in
positions of power but they have this
prospect disproportionately greater
responsibility but all of us need to
think about what am i doing how am i
contributing and we need to release that
leader inside and actually start making
the positive impact this world is
calling for right now but we have such
hierarchical leadership I mean I
understand what you're saying it's nice
to release the leader inside but in
these corporations
the truth is it's extremely hierarchical
what can companies do to create less
vertical and more horizontal
relationships well I'm a big believer
and I'm long been passionate about
closing the gender gap and I really
believe gender balance leadership is the
way to go in order to embrace a
leadership style that has been shown to
be more powerful and that's when both
men and women embrace both masculine and
feminine values it actually is proven in
research that that's the most effective
leadership style but I'm increasingly
now thinking about
we close the generational gap because
look at these young children on the
streets around the world they're asking
us to lead and Kofi Annan used to say
you're never too young to lead and then
he would add or too old to learn and I
think we have now entered this era where
sort of we need the wisdom of those with
experience but we need the digital
natives of the young generation to
co-mentor or to mentor us just as much
as we can help with wisdom from the
older people so it's a new reality and
these old sort of hierarchical ways to
think about things they're increasingly
coming under pressure in this reality
and you've actually called that the
hubris syndrome can you talk about that
well yes I am
I think hubris is can is our cancer and
leadership that's when leaders think
they know it all can do it all have all
the answers I don't think they need to
surround themselves with people who will
make them better which to me would in
some cases be more women and younger
people and and people who are diverse
and have different opinions in general
and hubris syndrome is so present than
leadership still and we know many
examples of them I don't need to name
them and the problem with that yeah we
know them and all over the world not
just in this country but that kind of
leadership doesn't unleased leaders in
others and no one person or no one
sector even has the solutions we now
need to come up with the creativity and
collaboration we need and the bold and
the brave leadership we need to come up
with solutions that cross government
private sector civil society young
people older people people of all
different backgrounds coming together is
the way to solve the issues that are in
front of us do you see that kind of
leadership coming from the bottom-up or
the top-down or do you think a crisis is
going to force us into a reexamination
of all of this well as someone who lived
through the most infamous financial
meltdown in my home country Iceland I
hope we don't need another one to learn
or to wake up but I do see that we can't
choose one or the other it is going to
have to we do have to transform the way
we do elite from the top the boardroom
the CEOs we
we do have to transform that but
increasingly we will transform that
because we have these social movements
coming from the bottom and throughout
society and the solutions exist the only
thing that's missing is will so if we
just all kind of find a way to embrace a
moral compass of our own to figure out
why we exist and how we're going to lead
and if we embrace courage and humility
in equal amounts each one of us can be
part of this 10-year period where we can
dramatically transform the world we live
in and make it just and make it about
humanity and not just the financial
markets well we have a lot of people
here who I bet have questions for you
and we have a few minutes for questions
so is there anybody that would like to
ask holla a question hello my name is
Sheryl I'm an aspiring leader and I have
a question about how do you lead when
you have no influence if I am just an
analyst and I want to speak to senior
management about a change that I feel
like will affect the whole company how
do I go about changing their minds when
they feel as if they've had
relationships that are said that their
way of business is said how do you
change minds when you have no influence
well thank you very much for that
fantastic question so sometimes people
at the top won't listen but it's
interesting that with the low trust we
have in society right now the greatest
trust we have is actually between the
employee and the employer according to
recent research so I think that
relationship may be the most powerful
way to actually transform the way we do
things so I would start by trying to
build the coalition for your good idea
and I don't know a single leader who
today will not listen to a concern that
many of their employees hold I'll give
you an example from another be team
leader Marc Benioff the CEO of
Salesforce he's really been outspoken on
homelessness in San Francisco on LGBTQ I
rights and all of the things that he's
been standing up for he does because his
employees
care about them so don't ever think you
don't have power if you don't sit in a
position of power find a way to go
convince him or her and mark for example
was convinced to close the gender pay
gap by two of women who worked inside of
his organization who told him we have a
gender pay gap he didn't believe it he
say bring me the data they did and he's
smart enough to know he needs to do
something about it I was one of the
first tech leaders to step up and do so
voluntarily so don't ever think that you
don't have power even if you don't sit
in a position of power but find other
people to support you and and and make
the case thank you anybody else any
other questions hi I'm overwhelmed by
fascination with everything you're
saying so thank you I just wanted to ask
how like diversity in opinion and
thought and also background has impacted
your leadership ability and what do you
think is the barricade that is limiting
the overflow of diversity in all
business settings and what do you think
can impact the change in that setting
but also the to disrupt the overflow of
like generations of people like staying
in place and what you think is the next
step to breaking certain like several
glass ceilings we're gonna do an entire
salon just on that question I think
Brynn sided well but let me try to touch
up on it so the way I see gender it is a
spectrum that's available to you know
men also have gender we sometimes forget
about that and I really we sometimes
forget about that and I I actually
played a very masculine woman early in
my career because those were the rules
of the games and I achieved some success
with it but fortunately I got to a place
where I started embracing my feminine
side as well but I would still say that
the best leaders embrace both both women
and men but I see gender also as one of
the most powerful levers to shift values
in culture so the reason I'm so
passionate about women in leadership and
believe that that balance is needed is
because right now our definition of
success is incredibly masculine
it's about financial profit alone or
economic growth alone and we all know
that we need more
than money I mean we need wellness
well-being of people and there is no
future beyond the well-being of our
planet so I think gender may very well
be one of the most powerful levers to
help all of us shift our economic and
social systems to be more welcoming and
the answer to your last part it's so
complicated but let me try to give you a
short one I believe that the way talent
and consumption is shifting is gonna
increasingly get companies to look at
adding difference into their leadership
because sameness is not working and
difference is a super power difference
is a super power thank you very much
hala thank you so much I wish being
talked to you all day
[Applause]